tout est bon pour se défoncer suffit d'y
croire un peu de tabac et quelques
morceaux de compté Stéphane mermillot
Enselme lui se fait des joints au
fromage il s'est aussi construit un
attaché caise à fondu pour pouvoir en
faire partout j'aimerais bien pouvoir en
faire en survolant l'équateur dans une
tribu en Afrique stéphane est le seul
type que je connais avoir fait une
fondue dans le TGV ils ont rien dit les
contrôleurs au contraire les deux
contrôleurs on ont mangé ils étaient
très contents on a bule blanc et tout
c'était c'était super Stéphane fait
aussi de la fondue dans la rue je mange
la fondue dans la run pour me faire
plaisir les gens qui s'approchent je
leur propose un verre de pinard et je
leur offre un mceau de pain on est tous
là à plonger son bout de pain dans dans
la même marmite on est on est on est
face à face et puis puis on s'amuse
bien et voici également le parfum fondu
alors je m'en mets pour aller dans les
night club le samedi c'est redoutable je
t'explique pas la gueule des
MU